the Prime Minister has accepted the
recommendations of independent pay
review bodies who it turns out agree
with what workers and unions have been
saying for months wages have to rise if
public services are to remain
sustainable so police and prison
officers will get a seven percent pay
rise teachers get six and a half percent
Junior doctors six percent and the Armed
Forces five percent now this is much
higher than government budgeted for
they'd allowed for a 3.5 increase which
leads 5 billion pounds to fine 2 billion
this year and 3 billion next which he
sunac says will come without any new
spending or borrowing it says around a
billion a year will come from increasing
the cost of Migrant visas and the
surcharge they pay to use the NHS so in
five years that raised less than 200
million a year the rest will come from
efficiencies that's cuts and delayed
planned spending so is it fair well this
week the ons said that public sector pay
was already rising at 5.8 percent that's
the red line here you can see it's
already in the band of these pay
increases which we shaded in blue but
it's still below the private sector pay
average of 7.7 here in yellow and well
under inflation still running at 8.7
well what does that mean for the cost of
living well let's look at inflation with
the bank of England's forecast for the
next few years added for now even after
these increases because inflation is
higher there'll be a real term squeeze
on wages but if inflation Falls as
expected below six percent by the end of
this year the value of wages will start
to rise in real terms too though of
course everyone will still be paying
higher prices now the government says it
won't borrow to pay for the Rises and
this is why public sector net debt the
end line there in red is more than 100
of GDP the Prime Minister says
increasing it would be inflationary in
the office for Budget responsibility
which has warned the UK's public
finances are in a risky State agrees
the context in which this chance is
working is much more challenging he's
got a much higher level of debt and the
interest on that debt is rising and is
rising Rising rapidly and that's eating
into his room for maneuver that's easing
into the fiscal space he has to do with
these pressures on the public finances
if these settlements end the year of
strikes unions can claim Vindication and
ministers can still argue they acted
responsibly the economic reality though
is the public sector like every employer
has to offer competitive pay if it's to
find and keep the people that we all
need